PS4 is way better than Xbox one.
I just made half of you very angry.
Here’s why.
Hi there, welcome to DNews, I’m Ross Everett
and I’m about to blow the lid off of super-fandom.
Think of a product you love, whether it’s
an Xbox, an iPhone, a certain brand of cracker,
as boring as that may be, anything really.
You have a positive reaction to it, it’s
good to you, and even when it’s not, you’ll
overlook it because it’s your product of
choice.
Now think about their competitors: Play Stations,
Samsungs, One Direction, arrrgghhh they make
me so mad with their worse controllers and
their large screens and big eyes.
But it turns out that fanboying or fangirling
over a product can be explained with some
very relatable social science.
And, I’ll even tell you how to break free
of it, if you want to.
Check it out.
Social identity theory is basically the idea
that as human beings we like to belong to
a group.
It gives us a sense of belonging, community,
camaraderie…
But it puts us into a group of US and THEM.
And Us are always better than Them because
let’s face it, it’s us we’re talking
about.
One of the ways we define ourselves is by
the stuff we own, like iPhone users or Xbox
One owners, so much so that it actually changes
us at a neural level.
In fact, we actually get a positive response
in our prefrontal cortex when we look at things
we own compared to things we don’t.
So when I hold up this iPhone[a] [*don’t
show apple logo*], some of you are having
a positive reaction and some of you are ready
to leave a nasty comment on this video.
So why does this happen?
Why does there need to be a negative response
to them?
Well, people categorize themselves and others
by status, and clearly we want to be the higher
status.
But there can’t be a high status, without
a low status group to be compared to, which
is exactly why the people who like Justin
Bieber attack people who like One Direction
in order to raise their status.
Also, check this out, the more time and money
we invest into a product the more attached
we are to it and feel the need to defend it.
If it wasn’t the best, would I just be an
idiot pumping my precious time and money into
the not best?
I should think not.
Clearly, I am smart and have been using my
time and money well.
That’s your brain defending your decisions
and inadvertently making you a fanboy.
But why do we keep going back, product after
product?
The new iPhone is announced and people are
already lining up to buy it without even a
glance at their competitors.
Well, that’s because of a little thing called
Choice Supportive Bias.
Choice supportive bias can actually create
false positive memories around a person or
product we’ve chosen to combat buyer’s
remorse.
This makes us defend our previous purchases
without any real critical thought.
So, how do we break away from all this?
I don’t want to be a slave to my human brain,
or more accurately the companies taking advantage
of my human brain!
Well, step number one has already been completed.
Learn about fanboyisms so you can identify
them when they’re happening.
Take a step back when you feel yourself getting
riled up and really look at the facts.
Allow yourself to be honest about the product
or person you’re fanboying about.
And most importantly, when talking to someone
about a competing product.
Make sure they ask your opinion before launching
into a tirade about why your phone or band
or game system is better and how theirs is
actually making them dumber.
And, if you guys want to see a prime example
of this, you can watch this Apple Fanboy tell
you exactly why the new iPhone and Apple Watch
aren’t going to change a damn thing in this
video.
It’s me.
I’m the guy.
Thanks for watching DNews - and if you want
more of it, be sure to subscribe.